I think only in the sort of last 10 or
20 years that different approaches to
mind have become to be explored kind of
quite seriously and of which the
inactive the embodied the ecological the
embedded are ones that interest me uh as
you been talking about David Charmers
he's very famous for uh the extended
theory of mind which unlike many of my
colleagues I don't bracket together in
the same way as the other four that I
mentioned because it seems to me that
David Charmers and Andy Clark extended
uh theory of Mind actually is just
another way of getting touring machine
functionalism or computationalism in
through the back door uh I see it's just
a backd door route to good oldfashioned
AI which is to me what the other for is
a kind of rebelling against so I unlike
many of my colleagues I partition off
charma's uh uh extended theories of Mind
away from the embodied the enactive the
ecological and the extended